good morning believe nation today's
message is get experienced over to you
and Jason statin you're always anxious
if you're gonna do something that you
haven't done before or if you're going
to test yourself but that's the reward
if you can you know go through that in a
successful way there's obviously some
reward there but you know it's all down
to experience you know nothing and I
think I could have done something as as
heavy as this in my former years you
know I didn't have the experience to
draw from you think I think this is a
really really really awesome rule
because this is one of the ways that I
have been able to expand my pop guardian
business because I think I just try to
get experience wherever I can whenever I
can I don't necessarily need a client I
just saw an aspirational client and
brought some coupling for them and I
practice on my friends businesses as
well so I just got experience wherever I
can and I think it's really helped
increase my skills and my passion for
what I do I think you know in business
value ultimately comes down to you be
able to produce something that people
care about right you want to make money
as an entrepreneur you got to provide
value the value comes from you have an
experience to know how to solve some of
these problem right like if we're making
business super simple right I have a
skill that can help you solve a big
problem there from providing value
therefore you're gonna pay me so the
question becomes do you have the
experience to be able to help people
solve that problem provide that value I
think a lot of entrepreneurs maybe start
a little too soon in that they don't
have enough experience with ID real
value and then you
there and you're frustrated that you
know you're not getting paid what you're
what you feel your work but really you
are not providing enough value to your
clients and so if you feel like you
don't have the experience then go get
the experience and even come in two ways
one doing volunteer projects you know
getting involved taking on smaller
clients just to build up experience and
to go work for somebody right like find
somebody who's done what you want to do
right you want to build a 10-person
digital agency go find somebody who is
running and created a 10-person digital
agency will work for them I learned from
them the point of having a job is to get
the experience not to get paid and
you're making contacts you're making
mistakes or understanding how something
Howey that industry works on the
meanwhile starting your business on the
side of the keeper by god when you feel
like you've tapped out that job
experience not learning anything more
and you have enough guide goodbye to
your clients and that's when you can go
full-time I just think too many
entrepreneurs start without having
enough experience to provide enough real
body to clients and and you don't make
enough money you complain you get all
upset or if you can increase your
experience that will increase the value
your clients will increase how much you
get paid and increase your positive - I
think a lot of entrepreneurs or weirder
they don't have enough experience when
maybe they might have some so if you if
you don't think you do go go get
experience wherever you can and then it
will increase your confidence so that
you know
you can't get value to your clients so
the question of the day today is what
are you gonna do to get experience what
are you gonna get experience leaving the
comments below will join the discussion
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shots of espresso